is Professor Nessa Goldberg from Oxford
is something a leader in counting and
lots of other
okay thanks um so I think it's
impossible to follow my father's this
but this is a less deep talk and I'm
gonna be talking about approximating the
matching polynomial and this is joint
work with Ivana who's here and with
andreas Galanos and Daniel Stephan
kovitch which I think also everybody
here probably knows okay so actually a
whole lot of this stuff that we're going
to be talking about has already been
introduced this week but I don't know I
don't know whether for the online one so
I'm going to quickly redefine everything
so that we have the definitions um so
what's a matching we know in a matching
is it's a set of edges but each vertex
can only touch one edges and so what's
the matching polynomial well we know
what the matching polynomial is so if I
can get in a graph of G I'm gonna use M
sub G to denote the set of all matchings
of G so sets of edges that don't touch
it a vertex and the matching polynomial
is the sum over all sets matchings of
gamma to the number of edges in the
matching so for example if I had this
little map draft we here's the partition
function so there's the empty matching
there's five matching with one edge and
very matchings with two edges and so on
and we've already seen that this is also
called the monomer dimer partition
function okay so what I'm going to so if
that various talks about this and in
fact yesterday we had to talk about
bounding this partition function and
what I'm going to be talking about today
is how difficult it is to do this
algorithmically so so the idea is we're
going to be interested in
you'll be given a graph G and some fixed
parameter gamma and we'll care about
which gamma and then we want to know how
hard it is to approximate
or to evaluate I'm at least
approximately this polynomial okay so
I'm going to start by just commenting
briefly on the exact problem and even if
you take gamma equals 1 then this
polynomial just counts the number of
matchings and it's been known ever since
the days of valiant and what number P
was first mind defined that this is a
number P complete problem and it stays
hard even if you go down to a bounded
degree so if you go down to dealt equals
5 or whatever so I'm not going to be
talking about exactly evaluating this
but rather about doing it approximately
and budget does really early work about
this and so going back into the into the
80s German and Alistair
gave an algorithm for the case where
gamma is a positive real number and they
gave up fully polynomial randomized
approximation scheme and it took me so
long to draw this picture but I'm going
to tell you briefly what their algorithm
is but actually the reason for the
reason for showing it to you is that
them their algorithm has an interesting
property that it works for all graphs so
there's no bound on the degree and
that's the last algorithm that I'm going
to talk about that has this property and
I'm going to be interested in this talk
in what constraints we have to put on
the graph and actually most of this
workshop we've been talking about
bounded degree graphs and one of my
themes is trying to get away from that
with deterministic approximation but
let's let's just go back and look at
Markov chains so if Gambel were a
positive real number then what they did
is they looked at a Markov chain but
samples from the gibbs distribution we
need the gibbs distribution anyway so
what is it well it's just the
distribution that samples are matching
with probability proportional to gamma
to its size so gamma to its size divided
by the partition function on the Markov
chain pick an edge uniformly and for
example if it's matched but number none
of its neighbors are then you know with
some
ability kick the edge out with some
probability stay if you happen to pick
an edge that's out and so are its
neighbors with some probability put it
in with some probability stay and two
comments about this so one if you look
at the chain it's um it's easy to show
that the stationary distribution is
exactly what you want and it's a harder
to see that it's rapid mixing but that's
what they showed but you can see that
it's really important that gamma is a
positive real number because otherwise
these transitions don't really make
sense okay so to keep in mind then if if
the graph is unrestricted and gammas are
positive real we've got this result now
what about deterministic approximation
well I know what I've got to do is I've
got to look at the case where we put
some constraints on the graph so let's
suppose for example that the graph has a
degree bound at most Delta and in that
case there's a deterministic polynomial
totally polynomial time approximation
scheme by a bunch of people prasad is
here i don't know whether any other
maybe other authors here - I don't know
um but anyway they were able to
approximate the polynomial in this case
and their method is correlation decay
and I'm gonna Chuck I'm gonna just some
about their algorithm because actually
I'm going to be interested in talking
about what what correlation decay can do
for approximating this polynomial okay
so so I'm gonna I'm not in case anybody
hasn't seen it I'm gonna tell you what
what does that even mean so here we
thought this this partition function we
want to approximate it I say we're gonna
use correlation decay so I'm going to
tell you what that is and by the way if
anybody has questions or hasn't seen it
feel free to to ask okay so so
correlation decay then um so I've got a
couple slides correlation to K 1 2 3 and
so on and kind of over the course of the
talk and then a kind of tug try to tell
you a little bit more and a little bit
more and hopefully if you haven't seen
the method before then you should know
how to use
it by the end of the talk so that's kind
of a goal okay so the first little
snippet is that um if you wanted to
approximate the partition function it
would really suffice to approximate
marginal probability and here it is a
probability because we're still in the
case that gammas are a positive real so
what do I want to do so I wanted to find
Zedd of G minus V of gamma so that
should be the contribution to the
partition function due to all matchings
in which V is not matched so the sum
over all matchings that don't match the
vertex V of that and so the marginal the
unmatched the unmatched divided by the
whole partition function we're going to
call that P V of a G gamma and so
clearly what that is what that is is
that if you sampled a matching from the
Gibbs Distribution that would be the
probability that this particular vertex
V isn't matched
yeah okay and okay the first claim that
we need for correlation decay is just
that approximating this probability is
actually the same as approximating the
partition function for all practical
purposes and the reason for that is that
you could just pull the the Z up and the
P down actually I think I wrote it
somewhere here and so the partition
function is just the the partition
function with the unmatched divided by
the probability so if you could estimate
the probability and you wanted the
partition function all you would need is
one recursive problem so that's a really
efficient thing so if you could
approximate this probability well then
you could recurse and so on so so we
just need to approximate the probability
and that's all all that we need to do
okay second fact about correlation decay
is that if you really want to estimate
the partition function
it actually services to estimate it on a
tree you don't really have to consider a
general graph and in the case of the
matchings polynomial this goes back to
god's --all in
like about 1980 and um this tax is not
very very hard to show actually um but
what he showed is that if you take a
graph but maybe that one and you want to
calculate the probability no so the
probability that that V is out then it's
exactly the same I mean formally it's
the same it's the same same polynomial
well same rational function as what you
would get if you estimated the same
marginal in the self of avoiding walk
tree which is just the tree where you
start from G you start from V and you
just enumerate all walks from V that
don't visit itself so you know from V
you can go to U or W but once you're at
you without going back you can only go
to W in and so on and okay for some
reason I wrote down the polynomial for
this particular graph but I mean if you
want to prove that it's the same I mean
it's always the same in every just
algebraically it's the same thing okay
so if you wanted to estimate this
marginal on a graph G all you would need
to do is is to write out their self
avoiding work tree and estimate you know
from that vertex that you care about and
estimate the marginal probability there
okay so that's good the good thing about
trees is that um they're really easy to
work with because we have natural
recurrences and later in this talk we're
going to need the particular recurrence
for the matching polynomial so I've gone
ahead and written it out because it's
nice and easy so let's suppose I had a
tree may be the self avoiding walk tree
and I've got some vertex V and some
vertices below it you know let let me
use TI to note the tree below vertex I
then let's just try and write down some
of these things so what is the partition
function for the matching polynomial
given that V is not matched well there's
not mad
then I can do whatever I like in the
ice-sub tree for all of them so this
partition function is just the product
of the partition functions that all the
subtrees but if I wanted the whole
partition function well either we could
be unmatched or else for one of its D
children I could match V to the children
the child so I can factor of lambda for
that then I better look at the recursive
polynomial corresponding to the child
not being matched and everything else
could do what it likes so that's
straightforward and the reason I wrote
those down is just that if you would
write down the marginal so which is the
V not match / everything and if you
would just look up there and divided by
divided I mean you have to do it but
suppose you need to chose to divide
through by that thing what you would
immediately get is that the marginal for
the tree at V is equal to 1 over 1 plus
gamma times the sum of the marginals the
children so we got this and of course if
your tree is just got one leaf then the
marginal is 1 because you can't match it
because you haven't found an edge okay
so we get this nice little recurrence
that one vertex the marginal is 1 and
otherwise if you just sum them up
multiply that you know ok ok so um so if
you wanted to compute this thing on a
tree you clearly could so far this is an
exponential time algorithm because the
self avoiding walk tree is exponentially
big so that brings us to the third
little principle of correlation decay
and that says that if correlation decays
and we'll see what that means then what
you do is you don't write down the whole
self avoiding walk tree rather you just
truncated to depth login you pretend you
knew all the marginals at depth LOC and
just pretend they're 1 and then compute
and then it's a it's an easy calculation
and correlation decay means essentially
that the error decreases geometrically
as you go off the tree so at your
truncated leaves obviously you've got
vast air
because you just made up the answer but
one level up it's a little better one
level up it's a little better and things
multiply so by the time you get to the
top you actually haven't got much error
okay so that's correlation decay and
these guys I'm using that they managed
to give them a deterministic
approximation scheme for a bounded
degree graphs and you would keep seeing
this and I guess I don't know whether
anybody's actually explained it but it
just means that the you you input a
graph and you input and absalom which
says how accurately do you want to
approximate this thing so maybe you want
to estimate it in a within a factor of 1
plus or minus Epsilon and the runtime
you're allowed is polynomial in the size
of the graph and also in 1 over epsilon
so you're allowed more time as you need
more and more accuracy but only
polynomially so okay so that's the
positive real case
but what if gamma is negative or complex
ok I edited my slides last night because
at this point of my slides I had about
three pages explaining why you should
care about complex and I've erased them
because that doesn't not need it for
this meeting but anyway what if gammas
complex so we are the the most the
method that immediately comes to mind in
this case is is what was being called
the VAR Vinick philosophy for some
reason at this meeting so what is the
barber knock philosophy or algorithm
well actually we know I'll do this
quickly because we've seen it before so
look at our polynomial ok it's a
polynomial the degree is not too high
could certainly it's at most wow it's
almost an over 2 or whatever so I
suppose I can find an open set in
complex plane where the polynomial is
not zero I mean within that domain the
log is close to what you get if you
truncate the Taylor series to log in
terms so that would give you immediately
an end to the log n algorithm for
estimating the polynomial
a man was a missing piece supplied by
Pat Owen records which kind of get
clever algorithm for computing these log
M coefficients so as long as we have a
zero free region we actually get a
polynomial time approximation algorithm
and then well going back to Elliott's
first talk out to this come up in just
about every talk in this meeting and we
have this kind of really important one
known result that for this polynomial we
know that actually the zeros only occur
on the negative reals and actually
beyond that we've got a bound so the the
zeroes occur on the real access and
actually they're they're less than minus
one over four Delta minus one so
everywhere apart from this negative real
axis we get a good approximation
algorithm okay so dude it patro records
barber knock okay so the first piece in
our work was just a kind of filling in
the rest so obviously if I'm a satisfied
have all the cardioid and amazing
pictures I couldn't think of many
pictures to draw so a couple axes so
here what you have is anything easy easy
is easy and what we one thing we did is
to fill in the rest of the picture so
what we showed is that actually if you
pick gamma to be any negative number
less than this uh threshold of minus one
over four Delta minus one that actually
the proximation problem is number P hard
and um this is something that Vaughn was
asked about but um well because we have
negative numbers that's why you can get
such a strong form of hardness what this
means that if you fix any any very
negative gamma and you're given a graph
with degree of most Delta and you want
to approximate this polynomial it's so
hard to do that even if you even if you
approximate it you would actually
exactly solve some number
hard problems so this is um this is a
very strong form of inapproximability
okay so what a little say a little bit
more about so I've said if you
approximate the polynomial well it's not
there the polynomial but what does it
mean to approximate a complex number so
what do I mean
approximated and what do you mean a few
things so one thing that's number P hard
is approximating well here we're on
negative real structure this is a real
number so was so one thing that's hard
is approximating the absolute value of
the polynomial within I put here a
factor of 1.0 one so getting within 1.0
one of the right answer is hard number P
hard um if he remarked this 1.01 and we
more or less just made it up it's not
it's not important at all so you could
replace it with any number you like so
getting within a hundred of the right
answer a factor of 100 that's number P
hard and actually if you felt like you
could power it up and you could show
that getting within two to the n to the
1 minus epsilon is number P hard this is
not exponential and that's a little bit
interesting we don't know whether it's
hard to get within an X an actual
exponential and for some in
approximately result that is known so
that by anyway but you can power that up
hi I another remark I wanted to make is
that the hardness works even if G is
bipartite ok whatever but also we can
restrict G not to have not to be a zero
and I think that's important because all
of these um approximations are relative
and so if I say gosh you've got to get
within 1.0 one of the right answer and
then I give you a graph which happens to
be a zero then obviously you would you
would have to hit it on the head so the
there's not much difference between
approximation and exact but you can you
can um you can restrict your graphs that
aren't zeros and you still got the
hardness oh there's no kind of weird
cheating going on there
okay so that's hard and then the other
thing that's hard is um the partition
function is a it's a real number and
deciding whether it's positive or
negative is similarly hard so
approximating the arg additively I mean
just at the extent of turning whether
it's a positive or negative real number
okay so that's that's the summary for
bounded degree graphs now our actual
objective in this paper was not to stick
to bounded degree graphs but to try to
figure out how we could how we could go
well okay to fill in for the complex
plane but within the context of the
complex plane to go beyond this um so I
want to take a little excursion and talk
about relaxing this max degree
requirement and actually most of the
results that we have them not just
matchings but all these kind of in
approximability z-- there aren't many
results that aren't in these
deterministic approximations that aren't
about max degrees so that's kind of and
you'll see we don't so there's lots of
open problems something I was asked
about just last week was um was all
these kind of there's a concept of
average degree this nowhere dense and
somebody asked me whether I thought that
we might be able to do things like that
and I looked at it in the unit nowhere
dense is a graph class that includes all
sorts of stuff like for example planar
would be way below it so I think there's
a long way to go before we could um
before we could tackle anything like
that um but what we did do is we looked
at the connective constant which had
already been studied for the positive
reals by Sinclair Sinclair's trip estaba
davon kovitch and yen and okay so I'm
going to tell you what the so you might
have seen connective constant for
infinite graphs and they studied it for
finite graphs and the definition is
essentially the same in what you expect
so this looks looks ugly I'm going to
put it there just because we'll need it
but I want to just talk you through what
does it mean because
natural so so let's say let's look at
the number of walks self avoiding walks
in a graph from a particular vertex okay
so if I had a delta degree bounded graph
and I asked how many self avoiding walks
there were of length K well of course
there would be at most Delta to the K
because of the bound on the degree hi
and if I asked you how many walks there
are of length up to K well still it
would also be that most about Delta to
the K because the shorter ones don't
matter too much um
okay now the connective constant is
almost that just summing how many self
avoiding walks there are up to some
length L and demanding that it be about
Delta L the only difference is that we
don't care about short walks so you
could you could have a degree a vertex
of degree n who cares that we'd have a
whole lot of walks of length one but
we're only going to start counting once
you get L to about log n so connective
constant Delta a family of graphs has
connective constant Delta if for any
length we want to focus on which is at
least some constant times log n the
number of self avoiding walks up to that
length is at most Delta L and there's
another constant there but not too
important so roughly Delta L walks of
length L as long as that was big enough
okay and the rest are just constants
they don't really matter
this degree yeah I mean I'm natural I
mean sure I'll just add a vertex
stupidly yeah either a McGrath that's a
better answer
yeah nominate wilt answer all my
questions yeah I mean yeah Randall
aspires so GI Manthey so you that you
get
okay any other questions okay so that's
looking like a constant and if you
forget all these symbols just remember
that a and C or some constants like put
them in just because that's how the
results are going to get stated so a
family a family of graphs has connected
Komsomol Delta with this profile a and C
if all this rubbish and so their
constants there okay okay so what are
those guys do well they said that
Perfect's Delta when gamma is a positive
real then you can approximate this on
graphs with connective constant at most
Delta and this profile step doesn't
really matter for them because it's just
a positive result and no bound on the
maximum degree so this is the point so
the connect constant is bounded but the
maximum contributed ring can be
arbitrary and the run time well um we
noted already that an approximation
algorithm should have a running time
it's Paula nebula never of cylon and I
put the rest of the junk in just to
indicate that it depends on these
parameters we're not going to improve
that in the constant case we're just
going to match it but I just I mean just
just think about is the number of walks
the number of walks yours probably
inverse to the distance of the nearest
through to the arch
that's what it is what it's the inverse
of the distance to the nearest three of
the nearest route to there that's the
number of three like walks yeah and
that's not necessarily the same as the
little self was identified yeah okay
yeah yeah okay um so they just
correlation okay and we're going to two
but one thing that we tried that we
weren't able to do that I think is
really interesting is that we and we
don't our Meg we don't spend long enough
and maybe someone else can do it but it
would be really interesting to know
whether this barber knock you know
somebody somewhere that this bount gives
you the distance of the route nearest to
the origin this kind of connected
constant it gives you want to mention
from oh no yes yes because all the roots
are negative for you okay so I think
it's not true is what I think it's not
true is that jumping ahead you can
create you can create connective
constant whatever you like like you know
the roots on the real axis are all this
well you know what minus 1 over 4 Delta
minus one power sounds of those roots
well I'm so for example and I can take
em and this is like dumping a head but
he really cares I can take a cubic graph
yeah and suppose I could get cubic graph
and then I replace each other with a
huge tree yeah each end with an enormous
tree where the two leaves are really
really far apart then what I'm doing is
I'm decreasing the connective constant
of that graph as low as I want because
imagine that you want to take walks in
that graph and now if you wanted to
traverse an edge you have to go through
this tree but what you do is more like
more or less forced cuz you're walking
from a leaf to a leaf and so I think
push the correct
constant down practically to one which
is why if I if I just I'm gonna come
back to this that if I just jump ahead
the hardness results heard the
connective constant R Delta bigger than
one rather than cubic that's just and
that's because you can take a route for
the cubic thing and shift it and still
have really small connective constant I
don't know if that makes sense it makes
me think this we might take it offline
but I'm sorry I don't know okay I'm just
saying you can make the connective
constant really really low and so even
though there okay what was I trying to
say I'm trying to say even though there
are roots in this raining do you know
above minus one over four Delta minus
one I can still make the connective
constants really really small down
towards blonde anyway okay okay and
something will be interesting to do but
I don't have to do and we talked about
there's only briefly but they're really
interesting to try and figure out how to
use the Barbican and petal records
method for connective constant and
here's why I don't know how to do it um
in order to compute the coefficients
what you need to do is you need to
enumerate the graphs that contain a
particular vertex that are of a certain
size like log n so if a graph is bounded
degree then you know you can do that so
it's a bounded degree graph and so if I
want to know how many connected graphs
are sub graphs are there that contain my
vertex V well it's like V 2 then
whatever lengths so that Delta to the
whatever length its small so I think but
if I if I were to run it's not
unconnected constant I mean I could have
a if I wanted to I could have a vertex
you know with quick very high degree
degree N or whatever and then I mean if
I wanted to know how many size K sub
graphs containing this vertex well
obviously there's n choose K and so it
grows too big and you kind of need to
enumerate them and I okay so we don't
know how to do that so I think that's an
interesting question and maybe
that should be explored but this may be
but what we did in this paper is we just
went around that and we used correlation
decay okay okay and then then one thing
I wanna point out is that unlike the
bounded degree case we can't push the
algorithmic result to this sum to this
zone where you've got negative real
numbers which are above when the roots
start and that's kind of because of what
I was talking about that that ya connect
a constant okay and so the so the
connective constant hardness result that
is that for any Delta bigger than 1 and
whatever profile if you take one of
these you know if your connective
constant is at most Delta than the same
things that were hard before I should
have put all that junk on the slide are
still hard okay so that's hardness and
then then now then what we wanted to do
is say okay oh wow I didn't play the
list okay this thing I couldn't read to
remind myself to notice it and I forgot
we didn't show hardness on the whole
negative axis what we showed is that
there's a set of values and I'm going to
show you which ones in a minute that are
dense on the negatives axis for which
it's hard
so the conjecture would be that for any
gamma that's a negative number that the
problem is hard for a connective
constant but we didn't show that we just
showed that there's a dense set dense
over the whole negative axis and the
reason for that is because we had zeros
to work with and I mean there are
probably more ugly 0 is not based on
nice regular trees everywhere else um
and so the conjecture would be that it
would just be true but we didn't prove
that so we be just proof that you friend
gamma there's a good nearby as you like
okay and stand would you get an
approximation algorithm off of the
negative real axis and that's based on
correlation decay and I put in the run
time I don't know if you really care but
the the bottom line is it's kind of I
mean we were high we borrowed loads and
loads of things from the paper on the
positive real axis so it's hardly
surprising that we got what would amount
to the same running time and when are
you so it's kind of a it's a
generalization rather it doesn't create
anything there okay good and oh but so
what I wanted to tell you is that
there's an algorithm that takes as input
graph and in silence and and what does
it do it approximates the partition
function up to some factor either the
Zaid where is that the complex number
with norman most of cylon it's good this
is kind of the natural way to generalize
it if you write your F Prize in one
particular form but of course if it
looks a little bit strange it doesn't
really matter so if you you know it's
the same thing you could you could
approximate with it and okay you get it
right to mind the norm with anything
with it in multiple or the art within
okay um so that's the connective
constant we use correlation decay and
what I want to do next is talk a little
bit about I'm not gonna run through the
whole details of the correlation decay
but I'm just gonna kind of highlight
what were some of the some of the issues
for us and the main issue was actually
how do we so I've already hinted that
when we do correlation decay we we have
to have the distance between the
marginals at some level shrink as you go
up and that's still true and we have
some issue with how to actually measure
these distances in the complex plane in
such a way that it would work and Young
has already talked to us about using
correlation
okay in the context of the hardcore and
he talked about this green circle that
came up on a number of slice artists and
finish a green circle that came up on
some of the slides and actually got
talked a lot about the multivariate case
but but actually what they were doing
there was a correlation decay in the
complex plane because of they were
working they could kinda measure
distances using the norm and that didn't
work out for us so we had to work a
little bit harder but I also want to
mention doubt that Peters and Rex have
also essentially proved contracts in our
various ways you can at the point of
these slides it's just a saying that
there there are various things that can
work okay correlation decay the marginal
is not now a problem yeah a lot of the
stuff I just put it up as a reminder but
it's not new so you saw it before you'd
have to read it so remember we're trying
to estimate these marginals now they're
not probabilities because we moved into
the conflicts numbers but that doesn't
matter now what we do want to be on do
correlation decay normally what we what
we want to do in order to truncate the
tree is to say well if the margin rules
differ by some amount at one level you
know maybe I've got some some marginals
here and there and I run a step of the
recurrence how does it go down maybe by
some factor and support those a measure
at the question about how to measure
distance and and you got really lucky
then you know the L infinity distance on
the margin rules themselves would shrink
but why should it that's a little bit
too much to ask and so what people do if
you haven't seen this before
unsurprisingly it's a little bit of a
kludgy area you know we come up with a
potential function and instead of
instead of measuring the distances
between the UM the marginals themselves
we measure the distances between their
potentials and so of course what you do
is you apply the recurrence to the your
potential climbs you better be
invertible so that you can put it back
apply the recurrence in
distance as long as that goes down
that's fine
you still get a choice for how to
measure the distance and a lot of work
uses the L infinity norm and I just
wanted to kind of show you in case you
didn't see it before what's the standard
thing okay so you've got these distances
yah-yah-yah-yah you've got some
potential function maybe you hope that
now given the potential function that
the distances will go down and blah how
are you going to do that now you just
use the mean value theorem and you know
that there's some point between the the
potentials here and the potentials there
such that the difference in potential is
at the root is just the derivative of
law yeah yeah everything you have to do
okay so that's not very interesting but
the point is that what you can do then
is you get this formal I mean you get
this essentially the derivative of the
recurrence applied to the potentials and
you want to show that this thing is
bounded and if you do that you know
bounded by 1 minus Epsilon okay so
that's the game and when would Sinclair
at all looked at the positive reals
I think this is the only paper maybe
that does this early steel when I saw
I'm but I'm gonna make the following
argument let connective confident it's a
really it's a global thing it's not a
local thing something can go wrong
locally soil infinity is a bit stupid as
a distance measure and probably you
better use some other norm and the norm
they chose depends on the on the area's
parameters on Delta that's the
connective constant on gamma and so um
so I'm so kind of what we did to get the
algorithm to work was to try to figure
out how to generalize their their choice
of norm and their choice of potential
function which I've written here to the
complex case ok um but how do we how do
we so how much time go ahead okay so
yeah 5 minutes and so I'm just going to
talk briefly about this so how do we how
do we measure the distances
just do contraction well I wouldn't go
through the details but it's going to
turn out useful to Reaper amateur eyes
that always happens here so instead of
looking at these marginals I'm what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take gamma
and I'm going to Reaper amateur eyes it
as one over some value the square of one
over some value Q and the real part of Q
is going to be positive and these
pictures are just to spare you the
trouble of working out whether that make
sense and it works they make sense as
long as gammas not are negative real
which of course it isn't because the
roots are there and once you Reaper
ammeter eyes everybody that way then the
first step is going to be figuring out
when you apply the recurrence where do
they use them where do these X's
actually live and it'll turn out
actually that they live in an open disc
well a really nice open semi circle so
which is just um the radius is one over
the real part of Q and that's not very
hard to show so that was the purpose of
the Reaper ammeter ization and then the
way we measure the distances in order to
prove contraction is a kind of a
standard way of measuring distances so
if I have any open set such as the
semicircle in which we work and if I
have any curve EDA that just mount zero
one to some point from some a to some B
then the length of EDA is just what it
is the integral and if you if you apply
to function Phi mapping you to the reals
then you could get the length with
respect to Phi by integrating that and
that would depend on this the derivative
of Phi and then we define the distance
just to be the infimum so the distance
with respect to some potential function
which we're going to choose just to be
the infimum over all EDA's of the
distance so okay so what do we choose so
the potential function phi that we
choose it's kind of the derivative of
this max applied to the messages
is um well okay so it's essentially if
you remembered one over X times 2 minus
X it's like that but but working on the
real parts and it needs to be greater
than zero in order for this distance
measure to be a metric and actually also
it needs to be bounded because this is
going to come in but ok I mean I don't
want to belabor the point too much
especially because I've not got much
time left but ok anyway if you measure
the distances this way and then you use
a the Q norm that would be the right one
you get contraction ok so I want to not
say any more about that I want to close
by just in fact I don't need a slide for
this so let's just Park it want to close
by just saying a little bit about the
hardness results of that hardness says
that there's a dense set on the well ok
the hardness result says that for the
bounded degree case for every gamma
which is less than minus one of our fold
Delta minus one you get a number of P
hardness and that there's a dense set
where you do for the connective constant
and that goes down to Delta's one so how
does the hardness go and it's a little
bit like what Ivana was showing you in
terms of the hard core polynomial so in
order to get hardness what we show is
that if you start with any gamma in
there then big rigmarole what you can do
is basically mimic any edge activity so
we moved to the multivariate case by
showing that with the fixed gamma that
you're handed you can actually mimic any
gamma you like so if the user hands you
a gamma you can build a gadget that
looks just like that gamma and by just
like I mean so much like that the errors
exponentially small and so so that's a
big rigmarole and in doing that involves
looking at the zeroes and either okay
well it looks like this first you show
how to get reasonably close to every
gamma that you might desire and that's
done by some gadgetry and then there's a
kind of bootstrapping which is these
kind of math
so that power it up and having done that
you now are in the position of knowing
that these gamma values enable you to
mimic pretty much any edge activity you
like then we know some ejective ''tis
are hard to compute exactly like minus
1/10 I think is the one we chose and we
show that by doing some kind of binary
search you know taking some edge and
repeatedly changing its value we can
actually just narrow down that and
compute it exactly okay so in order to
close the one thing I wanted to show you
if I can find it the lab lab yeah yay I
wanted to show you what is this den set
just in case you're interested so which
are the ones that we actually show
hardness for in the connective constant
and you can see it's it's just
essentially the set of reals for which
regular trees give you a zero okay so so
it's this out of real such that gamma is
minus one over four or Delta minus one
you recognize that that's where the
roots start cos theta that's just for
some rational multiple of theta and the
point is that if you if you are not in
there then the regular tree of that's
theta is not zero but if you're in there
it is and that's helpful okay so I think
I should stop
[Applause]
any questions and so without clock we we
had some stuff in our favor of
Independence right so in fact um yeah
and Pat Tillman records also applies
actually for independence at Sinclair
eaja casted as matchings just because
that's what we are looking at our thing
so I would I actually we didn't look at
that so I don't know whether we can make
mother we can generalize to that but
well I mean obviously the hardness goes
through but um we didn't look for the
yes
so the question will be about with the
some alternative so there are poses high
temperature expansion and there is this
algorithm in statistical physics called
Warhol Gary okay yeah somewhere for us
for some problems recently right coming
from this approach and potentially can
also fight high degree right okay but
okay so my comments are mostly based
around ignorance so I've seen the worm
algorithm and I've certainly seen it
when the parameters are positive in real
I don't know what the algorithm is when
the parameters are complex but I guess
you're telling me that's all well
defined in possibly yeah I mean it's a
Markov chain essentially so I have to
have transition probabilities well it's
making two different space right so you
you map the whole thing onto the
positive reals or something state so
it's not my cheeks but will be some
other some jumps you'll be much more
much much much more significant than
just flipping so I think the problem the
problem for us it here is because the
parameters are complex it isn't that we
don't know how to prove mixing is that
we don't even know how to define you
know these are they're just complex the
weight of an individual configuration is
complex I know there's this kind of
quantum law and Karla stuff which I
don't know much about which maybe
enables that I'm bad maybe should tell
me about an interesting slide I I don't
whistles thank you very much we are
little bit high so we'll come back in
five minutes